Paul first for you after United 93 after
captain Phillips the energy and I don't
know the devotion it must have taken to
undertake another film within the what's
becoming a sad sort of sub-genre for us
to deal with terrorism what made you do
this I think because because I'm a
parent of young adults and I'm concerned
about the way the world's going
particularly the rise of this immensely
strong populist hard-right reaction in
the world at the moment and I'm not
talking about you know
Democrat Republican conservative labor
and our [ __ ] you know conservatives and
liberalism that that passionate
energetic debate is what democracy is
about you know I'm talking about
elements that are anti-democratic
and wherever you look in Europe and
certainly in the u.s. to these these
forces are on the rise and they're on
the rise because you know our economies
are not functioning as well as they
should and immigration and fear of
immigration is driving politics and and
there's a a movement towards the
irrational frankly and you can see it
you know Sweden four weeks ago elected
her and neo Nazi Party to hold the
balance of power that's the same in
Austria it's Germany has the AFD very
very strong indeed to the second largest
party and growing in the Bundestag the
AFD youth is even
further to the right in fact it's under
surveillance now in three regions for
being anti-democratic
Poland Hungary are strongly
authoritarian Italy now has a hard
right-wing populist government the UK we
have a problem
France obviously McCarron one but the
front mesh now we'll be back
Charlottesville
you know where do you you know you can
make a list Brazil last week we have
some significant issues for sure and
this touches on all of those but it's a
feature film and it's a feature film
that you and Englishman made in a
country that would feel I think a little
sensitive about this well you make a
film like this by asking permission of
the people involved which we did in fact
the first person I went to see was yen
Stoltenberg who was Secretary General of
NATO now but obviously was Norwegian
Prime Minister and is a very well I
would say a well-loved figure for his
role in bringing his country through
this and I went to see him in Brussels
precisely to ask him if he thought it
was would be helpful or not and I
thought he'd be a give a cautious
political read on it and obviously if
he'd said don't do it I wouldn't have
bothered to trouble the families
literally the first thing when I sat
down in his office the first thing he
said was you obviously need to ask the
families but I have really hope you make
this film because this thing is the word
he used was metastasizing and it's
coming at us fast and people need to
understand what's what's going on here
then we asked the families and of course
there's no group of people who
understand these issues more than they
do and they were strongly supportive and
have remained so having now seen the
film so but obviously I'm an outsider
but I was very blessed to have a
and all Norwegian cast and a Norwegian
crew and the exception of Billy there is
Norwegians quite fluent it's probably
picked up a bit yeah
no but it made it a special film you
know just setting aside the subject of
the film for a moment because it meant
that I was really helping then tell
their story rather than telling them
what their story was if that makes sense
absolutely
centre and Eunice this is your first
feature film you had to do it in a
language which is not your native
language and you were you know teenagers
very young 20 year old when when all
this happened what went through your
minds as you considered doing the role
and what did you learn about your
country yourselves this incident as you
did it yeah of course it was it was a
challenge to do it in in English but
when well I can only speak for myself
but when I learned that Paul was doing
this film I knew that this subject was
going to be handled in a very respectful
way and as Paul mentioned he he really
helped us tell the story and he was very
free in the way of he allowed us to to
improvise a lot and we talked much about
how it was because I think all
Norwegians to know exactly where they
were on that particular day and it's a
story that's very close to to all the
widgets and and I spoke to dallara
both before we started filming and
enduring and and when I spoke to her I
knew that I had to focus on her her
strength because she she shows up to the
hospital a few few days after and and
she's really there for the rest of of
the people who are on the island and I
was so inspired by by the
so I knew I had to focus on on our
strengths absolutely yeah and Eunice
yeah I think I said I said I think Paul
Greengrass is the perfect director to to
make a film about this because of his
previous films and the fact that we were
talking English even though it was of
course very difficult in the beginning
but I think it gave us a distance to to
the topic in the way that because we
knew this so well so it kind of helped
us to focus on what we had to focus on
and not to feel because I spoke with I
spoke with Villiger before we started
shooting and just a few minutes into my
first conversation with him I I realized
that the thing I need to focus on doing
this part is to really tell the world
how how brave II was to to go through
this whole recovery a journey and then
in the end go into this courtroom and
sit down face to face with a man who
wanted him dead and I didn't I really
wanted to do that in a respectful way
and and with heart and I didn't want to
overdo anything or or plate too big if
you understand what I mean and so so I
actually think that speaking English
helped me with that yeah and also a
different aspect of this was speaking
English allowed the film to be seen by
so many more people and especially young
people having it on on Netflix and and
that's so important because it's a story
about what happened in Norway seven
years ago but it's a story that it's
very it's very important for the rest of
the world to to see and to learn and to
see what could happen in Norway Billy
Paul made I think the aesthetically
correct and sort of morally correct
decision of starting with the crimes and
then telling the story from there
how difficult was it to keep everything
in balance not to have too much of the
crime or not to have too much of the
victimhood because then you would in a
sense robbed it of its strength I
suppose you know that's something that I
think happens by I mean asks why I think
they call it editing editorial a process
because you know at the beginning
everything is much longer everything
there's way more material than we
possibly would need and so as we went
along in the cut it became clear that to
keep it keep the you know just as per
terms of keeping audience on the edge of
their seat and not being in one place
too long and trying to keep all these
balls in the air at the same time I mean
it kind of happens by feel you know when
when is I'm I'm putting myself in the in
the seat of the audience trying to
figure out when do we want to see was
here when do we want to see what's there
what connections can we make emotionally
in the juxtapositions of each little
particular piece it'll keep the strength
of the piece and keep it you know keep
it exciting and keep it you know
gripping for an audience so a lot of
that happens over time and by sort of I
feel in brief what do you hope for this
film I need differently from the other I
hope that young people watch it that's
my biggest hope and that was why I
partnered with Netflix on it because you
know Netflix of course they're trying to
develop this theatrical genuine
theatrical identity now and this would
be one of the very first films where
they've done it you know a couple
hundred screens or whatever it is but
but when you link that with the platform
you're getting two young people millions
of screens actually yeah but no I'm so
about theater I know you are but I'm
talking about the little ones I know I
remember we're talking to my kids and
they said you got to do it on Netflix
because our friends won't go and see it
but the arthouse cinema which is what a
film like this would would reach and
that of course we would want it not to
be that way but that's the truth young
people don't ten
to go to art house films so you're
taking it to the audience yes because
young people I think are interested in
this I genuinely do believe well one
will presumably find out in the next few
days but but they're the ones who are
going to have to fight this as lipice
dad says in that final scene won't you
please thank our panel for this film